Pixar's new movie Cars 3 we'll be racing
onto the big screen this summer and
we've just got the latest details on the
new and returning characters we can
expect to meet we know from the first
teaser trailer that Lightning McQueen
suffers a catastrophic crash that will
lead him to reassess what his future
really is and pushing number 95 off the
track is an upcoming generation of cars
armed with bleeding edge technology that
can slice through the competition so
let's take a look at the car leading
this new wave of racers lightnings new
rival Jackson's storm
[Music]
Jaxon's storm is the face of the new
generation of racing cars and he's been
trained on high-tech simulators and
programmed for perfect technique and
maximum speed storm is a confident and
cocky young rookie whose piston cup
sponsor looks to be igniter IGN TR that
is and who's racing them but is xx storm
can outrun McQueen with a top speed of
214 miles per hour and can make 0 to 60
in just 3.6 seconds and he's voiced by
army hammer you'll have seen in numerous
movies including The Lone Ranger The Man
From UNCLE and the social network
helping Lightning McQueen to find a way
to compete in this new world of
cutting-edge tech will be his new
trainer Cruz Ramirez and here she is
Cruz is an unconventional young trainer
who leaps at the chance to work with her
hero Lightning McQueen when he arrives
at the Rusty's Racing Center Cruz
understands all the new technologies
that have helped rookies like Jackson
storm rise to the top and she decides to
work with lightning to help him find a
successful way back to the racing track
and the duo practice and trained
together during the off season to
prepare lightning for the Florida 500
event Cruz is voiced by cristela Alonzo
a stand-up comedian writer and actress
who starred in her ABC sitcom cristela
and whose voice enough heard and the
animated Angry Birds movie and returning
to voice of five-time Piston Cup
champion Lightning McQueen is Owen
Wilson so let's take a peek at lightning
in cars three
[Music]
you
[Music]
it's been rumored that this movie could
be number 95 final appearance on the big
screen and that cars 3 could be slamming
the brakes on the cars franchise one
thing's for sure though with lightnings
top speed being 198 miles per hour which
is nearly 20 below Jackson storm when
he's at full throttle lightning will
need to learn some new tricks and his
trainer crews if he plans to stage a
winning comeback on the track so guys
what do you think about the new
characters in cars 3 are you excited
about the movie and do you think it
could be better than cars or cars 2 I'd
love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below
if you enjoyed this video your support
is really appreciated so do feel free to
like it share and subscribe and you can
click any of the links here to check out
more of my Pixar videos on finding Dory
inside out and the good dinosaur thanks
for watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers